how to pay your employees
if you're first getting started and
you're thinking about bringing on team
it's a great step because you got to
realize you cannot do everything
yourself
and if you want to achieve your big
goals you have to have people under you
who can help
most people they'll get this question
wrong when they ask me
how do i pay my employees they're
thinking about
what salary should i pay them should i
give them equity should i give them time
off should i
you know what what should i get the
medical leave and benefits
all of the specific aspects of paying
them
you have to first think about giving
them
a reason to come and be motivated to
work at your business and this is what
most people miss
okay most people end up going to you
look at your workers
okay they can work anywhere why should
they work with you
if it's just because of money and
benefits you're gonna lose
because you're as an entrepreneur you
can't afford to pay
the highest rates and to have the best
benefits
and to have a gym in the office and
cater all their
other lunches can you maybe maybe i'm
delusional but if you have that kind of
cash sitting around
then fine go for it but most
entrepreneurs we don't have that kind of
cash
okay when you're starting up a business
you do not have huge money so if you are
just competing on
salary you're gonna lose
the main reason people will come to work
for you is you give them
a reason to work for you what do you
stand for what are you trying to
accomplish
most people go to a job and they hate
what they're doing ninety percent of
america wakes up
drive to a job that they hate can't wait
for the day to end so they can drive
home
and spend time with their family give
people
a reason to get excited about the work
that they're doing
what are they going to do at your
company what does your company stand for
what big problem in the world are you
trying to change and how can they help
if your company stands for something
you're going to be
a much better target for employees that
want to come and work for you
and from there you can figure out how
much you're going to pay them and how
many hours and all that stuff most
people miss that big picture
so here's an example in my business
i only bring on people who believe in
entrepreneurs
if you don't like entrepreneurs if you
don't believe that entrepreneurs can
change the world for the better
you're not gonna have fun at my company
you're not gonna enjoy what you're doing
you're working there just to get paid
and i don't want those kinds of people
and you're not gonna stick with the
business but if you love
entrepreneurship and you love helping
entrepreneurs if you love
giving entrepreneurs tools resources
ideas
and you see that change in their mood
when you've helped them and you see that
now they believe in themselves again and
you see that they're off
making huge changes and and building
great businesses and you
you did that you helped them do that
that's life-changing that's awesome
stuff that's what gets me excited every
day
and who wouldn't want to work for that
kind of company those are the kinds of
people that you need to bring
and it only happens when you stand for
something another great example
thinking about my team all of my team
they would work for me they would
volunteer for me
because they love the work that we're
doing
i pay them i pay them but they would
work for me
they would volunteer because they'd love
it
and when you can tap into somebody's
passion you're not just getting
their body in a room you're not just
getting their brain you're getting their
heart and their soul you're getting
something deep and meaningful and you're
gonna get their best work and they're
gonna give you things that you never
even thought was possible
you're getting their art that's what you
need for your business especially
an entrepreneur startup because you got
to take on huge projects and you need a
team who's not just going to do specific
tasks
but can take on projects for you i got a
response from one of my youtube viewers
arturo
hey arturo arturo watches all my videos
so he's watching this how you doing
arturo hope you're okay
arturo wrote to me he has a translation
service
he helps people who are going to i think
most of the dominican
translate from english to spanish and
spanish to english so people who are on
business trips
can can get by can get their business
done right arturo is the man to call if
you have a question
artiero loves my videos and he writes me
to say
evan i run a translation company
i want to partner with you to translate
your videos
from english to spanish i'll put your
video up and i'm going to create
subtitles we'll create a new channel
i'll take care of all that stuff
i'll promote my website in there but i
want to do this because i love the
videos that you're creating
and this could help so many people in
the spanish communities
who can't understand english and i had a
quick chat with him and like this is
fantastic why not why not expand and
reach i don't know spanish
i can understand maybe a little bit but
i i'm not i cannot talk in spanish
i love helping entrepreneurs i get
involved in projects that help
entrepreneurs
this is another great way to do it i'm
benefiting from it
arturo's benefiting from it and we're
helping tons of people in the process
and he came to me i didn't reach out
this wasn't part of my plan he came to
me
because my company stands for something
because when you watch these videos
there's passion in it right can you feel
my passion
there's passion in these videos i'm
helping people
and people want to be a part of that
people who believe in entrepreneurship
and in helping business owners out
it's definitely not for everybody but
people who love that stuff
they want to work with me because that's
what i'm all about and that's what you
need for your business too
what are you all about who are you
helping and the people who you're
bringing on you're not just bringing on
a program or you're not just bringing on
a salesperson
you're bringing on somebody who doesn't
just have the skills you need
but believe in the same thing you're all
about and have the passion to work for
your company and i'd much
rather hire somebody who is
incred insanely passionate about what
we're doing
love the mission of the business but
don't have all the necessary skills
because you can teach them the skills
they can learn the skills and if they're
excited about something think about when
you're excited about something
how quickly can you get better at
something you're excited about
versus when you're forced to learn
something how much of the stuff do you
learn from your school
from high school when you were forced to
read history books
and then write a test all that stuff is
gone at least for me it's gone i don't
remember any of that stuff
but things that i got passionate about
things that i wanted to learn myself
my skills jumped dramatically
salsa snowboarding famous entrepreneur
information i eat that stuff up and it
sticks and i get better at it
and i can put into everything that i'm
doing so those are the people you need
to bring on
above the skills now you get to have to
pay them
but it's not as big an issue this is all
in response to a question that comes
from one of my readers
on youtube viewers on youtube love you
guys uh
his name is edjatin hope i pronounce
that properly
anyway he's 18 years old young
entrepreneur i love it he's starting a
furniture company
and wants to know how do i pay my
employees
so the key here to start is you're not
just selling furniture
what are you doing what are you trying
what big problem in the world are you
trying to solve and you want to bring on
people who believe in that mission as
well
and the way that you're going to do it
by selling furniture
you look at apple you look at steve jobs
how it became so successful
apple doesn't just sell computers
apple wants and believes that people
who think differently and who are brave
enough to change the status quo can
change the world
that's what they believe in and they
just happen to create tools
to help people do that so you're not
just
selling furniture okay if you're selling
furniture you're up against every other
single furniture company
of which there are tons and it's gonna
be hard to stand out unless you drop
your price which i don't want you to do
you have to stand up with something else
what do you believe in what's passionate
to you
and those people those workers going to
come on board that's your number one
thing okay i hope you've taken that
from this video right i hope this is the
message that you are taking
that's the most important thing from
there okay assuming you've got the right
person in the job who passion believes
in what you're doing and has skills to
help your business
then how do you pay them if you're first
getting started out
i wouldn't recommend paying them full
time start part time because
you don't really even know what you need
and you've never even hired
and work with people before so there's
gonna be a whole lot of failures a whole
lot of
communication issues you're gonna have
to work on there's gonna be a lot of
mistakes that you're gonna make and so
better to start small and work your way
up
start part-time the first guy i hired
was for an hour a day and i built up
from there
and eventually hired people for half
days and then full days and then a few
days a week and then
and then full time you build your way up
at some point you have to discuss if
somebody is worth
giving equity to or not in the business
and if you're going to think about that
be really careful this is like getting
married okay this is a partnership
that's going to last a long time and you
have to make sure that you love working
with this person they believe in the
same thing that you're doing
and they're as committed to it right if
you can
think about your relationships and how
you date before you get married this is
the same thing you've got to really know
this
person know their personality know you
can work with them no you can get
through the tough times
anybody can get through the easy times
can you get through the tough times with
this person because you're going to have
them with your business
and then think about potentially giving
them equity so that's my quick
in a nutshell solution but number one
most important you're bringing people on
who believe in what you're all about
that comes from you standing for
something then number two
start part-time give them
whatever down to an hour a day a couple
hours a day whatever it is start
part-time make your mistakes learn what
you really need
move towards full-time and think about
equity only
if you really think that this person is
a long-term cornerstone to your business
and you can really really work well for
them
exciting times ahead for you i'm excited
for you believe
for those of you who like this video
you're watching you're thinking this is
great
i love it please give it a thumbs up
below i love seeing those coming in they
really make my day
keep me going keep me energized keep me
wanna do more videos for you
and if you have a question about
bringing on a team or another question
for your business
leave it in the comments below i love
reading knows i always do i read every
comment that comes in
and i will make a video response for you
if you ask a question so thank you and
i'll see you soon